my name is Matt Welch I'm the
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine
Nicholas bees the editor of Reason
online and TV he's somewhere here say
hello that's him there and I wanted to
thank you we're just going to talk for
about a half an hour here lightning
round from the beginning of questions
and Dave Weigel is going to set the
table for us a little bit let's leave it
over to our great political reporter
Dave White i will briefly introduce
everyone and then we'll start asking
questions Wayne Allyn root is a sports
celebrity a self-made self-made
businessman millionaire by the age of 30
our next panelist is Mike Ravel a micro
Bell was a senator from alaska from
nineteen sixty nine to nineteen
eighty-one bob barr he was a congressman
from georgia from 1995 to 2003 he joined
the libertarian National Committee in
2006 and our final panelist is Vern
McKinley he is a consultant businessman
a former a researcher for several
libertarian think tanks and he's running
for Congress as a Republican in Virginia
against an incumbent Republican who's
basically pretty awful big government
Republican tell everyone well why you're
running why this is your year I think I
can get people excited with a dynamic
youthful enthusiastic speaking style and
message that really will catch the
attention of all the young people are
followed rockwall we all know that money
in politics is what corrupts politics
and we've seen this year more corruption
than ever taken place in our history you
think you're going to see a change next
year from what we have it'll be more of
the same inside the heart of every
American beats the heart of a
libertarian and what we need to do is
show the American People that that is
mainstream for too long libertarians
have been silent there's a lot of
turmoil in the Republican Party
now I think last week you saw these
discussions about chaos in the party a
lot of the the moderate big government
types are getting pushed out of the
party and it's a great opportunity with
dr. Paul's lead and others to take back
the party like was done in the in the
early 80s and mid 90s do we have an
immigration problem first question I
love immigrants if immigrants canyon
without expecting welfare aid to
dependent families child support housing
free of housing assistance free public
schools free medical social security if
you could met wave a magic wand into
tomorrow i would say open borders would
be great let everyone in I love
immigrants but you can't it's
unrealistic so we have to seal the
border to stop the problem and then
figure out what to do with the people
that are already here the people that
I've met immigrants they don't come here
for welfare they come here to work they
come here to work and they love to send
their money home to their families where
the money goes a lot further than it
goes here no we've had a stupid policy
in this country I'm a shame that we're
building a fence in our southern border
what we really need to do is recognize
it even as libertarians the one
fundamental function of government and
if there is one responsibility the
government has is to protect the nation
to protect the sovereignty of the nation
and you do that by assuring yourself
that those people that wanna come into
America submit themselves to a basic
background check present verifiable
current identification at a proper
border checkpoint and that you make sure
they don't have a communicable disease
but what we don't want to do is to have
any kind of real ID type of employer
verification program that tracks all the
employees in the country we don't want
to be spending billions when we don't
really have a plan to straighten out to
the border situation that's what we've
been doing since 2001 okay next next
question head has any foreign
intervention by the United States since
the Gulf War been worth it I just you
put me on the spot as to which ones were
worth it's 91 I guess the festival or
because there
there wasn't attacks the first Gulf War
I guess you might say was it was one of
those examples when we had to go in and
protect wait in the oil supply but
having said that I certainly don't think
this Iraq war made any sense at all i
think it's a disaster i think we got to
get out as fast as we can war baguettes
war and it started with the first world
war a democrat took us into war we
should have let the Europeans settle
their differences and you not set it up
for the Second World War and then
forward just no time in history where
you can look at a war and not realize
that did not be get another war we need
to we need to recognize that America
does not serve either itself or the rest
of the world well by intervening
nation-building and occupying foreign
lands to clarify none of the
intervention since the Gulf War then
keeping in mind that most were under
Bill Clinton no I think Afghanistan I
would have probably voted for a very
targeted intervention there to take care
of al Qaeda because using Ronald
Reagan's national interest benchmark I
think that was something that was in our
national interest but I wouldn't have
stayed there for nation building like
we've done and the iraq war i would not
have gone in there okay next question
what is the first federal agency that
you would get rid of once you get behind
the desk the Oval Office that's an easy
question for me it's the Department of
Education I think the symbol of
everything wrong with our government
today I think it's the great issue of
our time it is the civil rights issue of
our time there are children and get a
gun as hell to our head I think back to
the Boston Tea Party its taxation
without representation when you force me
to pay property taxes to send my
children to public schools and public
schools are failing and I should have a
voucher that allows me to take that
money and choose something else and
unfortunately public school teachers you
do not want our children succeed all
they care about is their own salaries
and it's a sin and it's a disgrace
Department of Education God obviously
the I
and they our system of revenue has to
change it just give me let me give you
the overarching aspect of it you can see
in 24 seconds 24-second principe we tax
individuals we taxed a productive part
of enterprising corporations we tax our
savings but we don't tax wealth does
that not give a message to the American
people that we got things cattywampus
okay yeah I just did the word
cattywampus I don't think I i was
thinking of another word but i don't
think you want me to say it same
question first agency you wanna get rid
of there is absolutely no reason no
constitutional basis no legitimate basis
for the Federal Department of Education
all they do is spend money and interfere
that would certainly have to be either
add or very near the top of my list for
agencies departments and officers and
the government to get rid of education
obviously energy commerce commerce is
just a broom closet a bunch of functions
that shouldn't be around I mean these
are all planks during the Reagan years
during the mid 90s Republican revolution
and then this time around we need to
really be serious and get rid of them
all are you willing to legalize the sale
and possession of all narcotics the war
on drugs is the stupidest thing this
country has ever undertaken we know the
failure of prohibition in the 20s and
now there's nothing stopping up and here
I was there Richard Nixon commissioned
the study with the Pennsylvania Governor
Shaffer and the study was to find out
what the story was with respect to drugs
well they came back with a study that
said that marijuana was not addictive
with not a gateway drug and that we
should deregulate the hard drugs and if
you want a hard drug go to a doctor get
a prescription that's what the rest of
us do with drugs right now
what are you talking about speak for
yourself son why not wear something with
but wait you get older you'll need some
believe the war on drugs disaster but
having said that the way he elected is
to go after issue the American public
and get their hands around and I think
it's always about medical marijuana you
had an uncle of even a father yet
someone was sick they were how could you
deny them something that would take that
pain away their last stage of life we
have a responsibility to libertarian
philosophy the libertarian platform the
Libertarian Party to present our ideas
to maximize individual liberty and
minimize government power in a way that
actually moves us forward in the
American people to get to that point you
can't do it in one fell swoop from a
camp this says the state's do it I'll
give you a 10-second answer it maybe
shudder when I heard John McCain say
that his favorite president was Teddy
Roosevelt who's your favorite president
George Washington Burma can tie between
Ronald Reagan and Calvin Coolidge George
Washington far and away far and away
Thomas Jefferson was libertarian
president history of America we'll talk
later about the Louisiana Purchase and
what that meant for the expansion and
slavery with that I'd like to wrap up
our terrific event thank you to all of
our guests please give the great round
of applause
thank you also to a Dave White for
leading the there thank you very much
this is a Ben Matt Welch for reason TV
good night